i do love this shot hey yellowstone i
love this show i think it's fine kevin
costner's from compton kevin costner's
from compton but kevin costner also is
from
ventura what yeah i didn't know that you
know growing up in ventura you like
everybody's like kevin costner he's like
the most he went to buena high school he
went to the high school that my fiance
went to
wow i actually met kevin costner before
like in in ventura yeah in ventura we
were doing like this ventura like little
um
i think it was like a benefit concert
and
all of a sudden this like kind of like
security guard type dude walks up and
it's like hey you know kevin costner is
like
here and i'm like oh [ __ ] kevin
costner's friend he's like yeah right
there like you can you can say hi to him
it's almost like a invitation to say
what's up but not like kevin coster
wants to say hi to you just just so you
know he's right there you can talk to
him like oh [ __ ] you know i'm kind of
nervous
i walk up i'm like yo uh
kev
i was like it's nice to meet you man i'm
probably like yeah i know you are he's
like yeah you're mr ventura now and i
like
wow i wanted to cry bro kevin costner
called me mr ventura you know it's crazy
not that that's like a title somebody
has but if anybody can give that title
out to somebody he's pretty sure him
yeah as much as like kevin costner's a
legend field of dreams dances with the
wolves if i meet kevin costner today i'm
calling him john dutton you can call him
john yeah but that's even more lit
because that means he's still like if if
somebody can look at you like this
can i get a photo straight up as an
actor if somebody can look at you and
call you your character's name like
your [ __ ] is smacking right then and
there in the moment you know what i mean
yeah yeah